foreign
welcome back to another episode of the
ADI hour it's been a while it's been a
few months so I'm really excited to be
able to host another great conversation
and today I'm honored and thrilled to be
able to welcome Joanne Coach P McCauley
to the Addie Hour podcast Coach P thank
you so much for being here definitely
appreciate it thank you it's always
great to be amongst a dookie yeah that
was a good thing yeah definitely a good
connection there and for me I'll have to
contain my excitement because as our
listeners know I'm a Duke fan have a
Duke fan a Duke graduate so this is a
this is a full circle moment for me to
be able to host you after watching you
on the sidelines for so many years I
definitely appreciate just all the work
that you're doing as well thank you
thank you great to be here great to be
here excellent and by way of
introduction I just want to give you a
little bit of give our listeners a
little bit of background about who you
are and what you've been up to last few
years but of course that's something
we'll delve into in the conversation as
well but Joanne Coach P McCauley is a
former NCAA division one women's
basketball coach a position that she
held for 28 years and Ashley talks about
she's now taking on her greatest role
yet so she's foraging a path to
destigmatizing mental health and
coaching those afflicted by mental
health challenges to pass for a full and
productive life
as I mentioned Coach P is has a history
as an elite coach and a champion she's
LED teams at Maine Michigan State and
most importantly Duke not really but
from my perspective most importantly
Duke making National coach of the year
and winning numerous championships at
all three Schools she's the only coach
in history to win coach of the year and
four different conferences and she
achieved that five times she's also the
only division one coach head coach to
lead two different programs to 30 win
seasons and three National Championship
Games appear game appearances so someone
who has obviously excelled in her craft
but she's also a winner in life with a
powerful story as someone who is
diagnosed with bipolar disorder at the
age of 30 while coaching at Maine it was
something she wanted to reveal for
decades but she was counseled otherwise
because of concerns of the consequences
that it might have for her career and on
her teams and even despite these
struggles she also had about with skin
cancer but still successfully raised a
family and continue to Triumph in
basketball
but in 2021 she decided it was time to
shift and to talk and become a mental
health Advocate and speaker sharing her
story to inspire and educate others on
how to win without losing yourself
the result of her work has been a
best-selling book secret Warrior a coach
and fighter on and off the court
something we'll talk about a little bit
more today and she's also the author of
choice not chance rules for building a
fierce competitor
so again I'm just deeply honored to be
able to host Coach P here I'm grateful
for all the work that you're doing in
these spaces and outside of even the
mental health component all the things
that you do around mentorship is also
something that's near very near and dear
to my heart personally and in my
professional and academic roles so I'm
sure there's lots we could talk about on
this podcast but we'll try we won't make
the conversation go too long but I'm
just honored to be able to welcome you
here today it's thrilling I love it and
I love the work that you do I admire
work and brain health so much well
thanks so much yeah thanks so much and
in a sense I feel like the conversation
that we're having is these are the types
of things that have been really
gratifying for me even as a
neuroscientist be holding have these
Partnerships and these conversations so
we don't just get stuck in our silos
working on when we're working in
isolation when it has so much importance
and impact for our our society in
general so I appreciate your willingness
to come into for us to be able to engage
that to model it and hopefully to move
things forward in a very real way okay
well the podcast is fabulous the
diversity of your your cast I mean
everyone's got to be thrilled about that
yeah it's been a lot of fun and a lot of
learning and growth for me as well great
great well as my listeners know they're
anticipating this I always just like to
check in with people and see how people
are doing just in the midst of
everything that we're experiencing
obviously we all have our personal Joys
and challenges that we walk through on a
day-to-day basis uh but at this point in
time October of 2022 we also have
elections that are coming up in the U.S
all the tensions around that there are
obviously things that are continuing to
go on all over the world uh in Russia
and Ukraine the challenges that have
come up in Iran recently with some of
the women's rights issues that we're
still trying to see if things will
change for Brittany grinder coming back
to the country obviously just to name a
few but I always just like to put things
in context and just see how you're
navigating on a day-to-day basis with
all things personally in your life and
just we're on the world stage
I I think um well you mentioned Brittany
and um you know she's a fabulous person
and what she did at Baylor was
incredible I didn't know her personally
I don't know her personality
um but she was the reason why we didn't
go a final four go to a final four yeah
she had a three-point play in Memphis uh
that knocked us out Coach K and the guys
John Shire and Nolan they all went and
so we made it as far as Elite eight
together but we didn't quite get to that
final thing I remember that well yeah
um good times though a lot of success
and getting back to Brittany I just I
keep trying to think about prayers and
thoughts that she's a strong
she she's strong and I know this is the
biggest challenge of her life and I I
can't imagine in the world stage in all
regards is very difficult and I just I
try to focus in my world to do what I
can or mental health advocacy and
understanding mental health impairment
and and trying to motivate and guide the
best I can being a non-medical expert uh
but just definitely learning a lot in 27
years
that's really well said and I appreciate
just walking us through your your
thoughts and and concern
um in the midst of the work that you're
doing for Brittany and and that whole
situation but just also thinking about
how you're making an impact
um and it's interesting for me to hear
you speak as a coach I mean you're not
coaching anymore in that sense but to
kind of hear how that has translated
into what you're doing now and the ways
that you're continuing to coach in a
sense with a different or maybe an
overlapping Mission um so again for me
that's really encouraging but before we
delve into that a little bit just wanted
to have you also just take our listeners
through your path and how you got into
coaching in the first place and I guess
we'll get to touching in to the way that
you're coaching in society right now too
but just curious to hear about your
general path well I was very blessed
with great mentors and leaders on all
accounts I was down at Auburn as a
graduate assistant became an assistant
coach I learned from Joe champion at
Auburn at Summit to Uganda fabulous
people and I was a head coach at 26
because I'd have an enclosure wow the
final four is National Championship
became that head coach at 26 and
I was I read all coach K's books I
hadn't met him or anything but there
weren't as many books out at that time
so I'm a Navy brat and you know he's an
army person so I was really pulled to
that story and so that's when I started
studying uh Mike and Coach K and all of
that and I had eight years at Maine and
seven at Michigan State and that's where
I bumped into Tom Izzo and and we
actually did go to final four in the
same year right and that was quite an
experience I learned a great deal from
him and being working alongside a Coach
K for 13 years was quite an experience
and so I've been very gifted I've been
very fortunate and blessed to have
incredible mentors along the way
that's outstanding and great to hear it
was I'm curious 26 as a head coach was
that
surprising at that time was it an
anomaly I just thinking that's a
landscape I'm curious what your
experience was like at that point
um I was
well at that time I was the youngest I
think the youngest ever was Pat I think
about 22. wow
um you know I admire her greatly and I I
can't believe what what she went through
with her brain I just you know you can't
you can't imagine or even fathom that
um but I think at the time I was the
youngest uh division one head coach and
and I was coming home to Maine I'm from
Maine and so that was an enormous amount
of pressure
um State and some of that pressure
contributed to my
well my episode in finding out that I
was in fact somebody with bipolar
disorder so I guess there's that awful
experience but yet at the same time I
believe in the concept of the brilliant
mind and I do believe that if you seek
balance whatever balance you need to
seek that you will be your best
ever and so many people don't know that
they can get through it
yeah I think that's really well said
definitely something I want us to come
back to in the conversation as well
because one thing that has come up you
know on this podcast and just in
conversations is that idea as you talked
about getting back to a place of balance
but the idea of separating mental health
from mental wellness and this idea that
you don't have to be you can have a
mental illness and still have mental
Wellness
absolutely and at the same time you
cannot have a mental illness and not
have mental Wellness in terms of the
day-to-day activities how people are
spending their time so really
helping us as a society to think about
things that way and not to just put
those of us who are struggling into a
specific category of condemnation or or
struggling or hopelessness but to really
kind of have that piece and that's one
of the things I've really appreciated
with what you've been sharing with folks
um as well on this journey well it's you
know as you know and of course I'm
preaching to the choir here but um it's
a Continuum and what I feel about the
Continuum is it's become much more
blurred and now whatever was good for me
you know back in the day and I realized
bipolar disorder might be five percent I
don't know we don't know because many
are undiagnosable let's say five four
percent the reality is my ability to
relate is a hundred percent and then
what we've been through and so sharing
tips and ideas whether it's a simple tip
about sleep hygiene or something more
complicated CBT you know behavioral
therapy whatever it is we're more of a
Continuum for it so I guess that's a
good thing it's more Blended and as you
know brain health does not discriminate
I mean it hits all ages and all Races
and ethnicities and everything and I
think that's the thing actually that is
a great example to many other things in
our world is that we have to come
together it's a human thing it's a human
element and I think that's
has some irony in it yeah given all the
you know segmenting that's going on and
yeah I think that's very sad yeah I
think there's a huge opportunity there
and a lot of power as well if we keep
that human lens on things and use it as
a way to bring us together towards a
common goal as much as it can be used to
go the opposite direction as well as a
way to continue to divide people so I
think that's really a really important
point that you brought it as well just
to loop back a little bit as much as
you're willing to share if you'd be
willing to give our listeners some
insight you talked about the mentorship
about the pressure going back to your
home state and the first episode
um if as much everyone to share how that
all came about because I think it's also
very informative for people to be able
to hear a bit of Australian to have some
understanding because I think bipolar is
one of those things that unless someone
has walked with someone through it
sometimes it's hard for people to to
grasp or get a concrete sense of what
that really entails yeah it's pretty
hard to diagnose isn't it it's a tough
one
um what I can say is I was 30 and it was
a year after giving birth to my first
child
and we were getting that program wanting
to go to the highest level and all of
that had a lot of pride in being from
Maine the program was sort of bottomed
out at the time so it was a wonderful
opportunity
and I took it very seriously
and so seriously that I lost a dear
friend was coaching and then stopped
sleeping and I didn't think that was a
big deal I thought I was getting older
didn't need as much sleep
and that actually it gave me more time
to think and work and do
and my husband was not aware of
that I had sort of not had two or three
nights sleep I said I didn't sleep well
and but he you know what does that mean
right you know remember this is 27 years
ago there isn't a thought in the world
about brain health sleep hygiene
any of those things
um not in the way it is today and so I
thought wow you know this is good I can
be really efficient and productive and
then I think the fourth or fifth night
you don't crash you just
you know as you know the Mania
accelerates and the interesting part
about it was I was very good in front of
my team because I was very positive
I was projecting championships and great
things for the program I was organized
and on it and if you came to practice
you would have said wow what an
enthusiastic one and always coach the
positivity was through the roof
so they were taking that in but it was I
was fortunate it was sort of over a
weekend I believe
where my husband and a couple of their
friends recognized that I was losing
reality
and the biggest part that is in my
trailer is
I'm talking to a recruit on the phone
and I tell her that the TD's talking to
us you know talking to me and to her and
this was on my trailer which I present
when I speak
and she was a great kid I told the
University of Maine which is an
interesting caveat yeah and she said
what you know what do you mean Coach P I
said no I'm telling you it's telling us
you know great things and before I could
get into a long conversation John
grabbed the phone and he said Jamie
coach P's just having a moment here
and we'll we'll call you back
and so that's how that started and then
my husband had to trick me so to speak
that we were going for a drive to take
me to a hospital
and then I deducted oh there's something
wrong with him
um
you know so in my weird paranoia I
started to think about wow what's wrong
with him
so I happily went to this psychiatric
hospital I said boy we have to take care
of him and the reality didn't hit me
until they shut the door
it's done differently now
but the way what I had to go through was
a little bit different yeah and it was
kind of like a
One Flew Over the Cuckoo's Nest
kind of thing
and I was the door shut
and then I realized I couldn't get out
and so that's you know there's this
whole scene in the book that I cover
about being locked in and I run
around trying to get out
and they had to you know tackle me and
you know the shots on the whole thing
and
um so I try to
you know things have come a long way and
we should be very proud of that yeah of
where it's come and and so that was my
first episode and just very quickly my
second episode was only because I
stopped taking my meds because I thought
I was better I'm an athlete didn't want
to take any medicine
and my doctor said if you do that you
know you probably will struggle at the
time you don't want to struggle the most
and I didn't believe that but sure
enough in February in the middle of the
season I had a depressive episode and
most people think a depressive episode
is
um you know feeling weighed down but
it's also you can't read the newspaper
as you know you can't function I could I
couldn't write up a play
you know my it just was not happening
for me and then I couldn't coach in a
game
my jaw locked up I had allergic reaction
and long story is I had to bring this
team in and tell them that I'd let them
down and that I hadn't taken care of
myself and after that when I did that
and the good news is we won a
championship that year this morning we
did lose that we did lose that gain
right or 30 points and because the women
knew something was wrong with me yeah
so that was my story then and I've had a
third episode and ironically that was
after leaving Duke after getting out of
coaching wow completely wow I think
that's significant because people think
oh
it's all this pressure
that forces these things and if that's
the case I do have one example of that
my first episode but my third I was on
vacation
different story yeah and so I think it's
important to recognize the complicated
nature of it yeah yeah
that was really well said I mean again
just appreciate your love level of
Candor and so many I mean so many
important lessons that you even just
talk through and talking through your
experience I mean thinking about the way
that your husband that family stepped in
and was looking out for you and paying
attention I mean that's such a key point
for those who are willing and able to
actually notice differences and then to
be proactive and help you navigate
through that but then also just even on
your part just the um
the humbling experience that it must
have been even as it was realization was
coming along different ways as you
talked about your first experience at
the hospital or things that happened
since then the aspects of resilience
that you had to show up and also just
navigating knowing how to navigate
having one experience not taking
medication how that impacted you so I
mean so many important lessons that you
just shared even in just walking us
through that so so kindly which I think
is important and even I mean that last
example about the vacation again just
the complexity of these challenges and
it's not always predictable not what
people may think so I appreciate you
taking through that and for those who
haven't heard or you know have that
concrete aspect I think it's just really
helpful to even hear what that looks
like because in so many situations like
you mentioned with the coaching the
manic science is hard for people to
grasp because it looks
so productive in a lot of ways yeah it
is yeah it does and it feels that way
and you know what's really marked by my
experience is a death if you go back to
my first experience
um
it was the pressure of being a coach and
it was the death of a dear friend and
supporter and all of that kind of you
know kind of went in a direction and and
I and and the timelines aren't always
clear as you reflect backwards and then
interestingly upon leaving Duke in July
of 2020
my episode does not occur until June of
21.
and but yet I have a cancer scare I have
a hysterectomy and then October 18th
which is today this is two years now my
father passed so I had my father passing
and I sort of made it through I made all
these responsibilities and different
things going on
and then I was going up to Michigan and
on vacation
and it was the human connection piece
that was costing me I have lost a lot of
supporters that loved me because I was
with Duke
well I wasn't with Duke anymore yeah and
so and that's not being uh negative
towards people that's human nature yeah
yeah I wasn't associated with Duke and
so my commonality kind of wasn't there
as much the circle gets a little smaller
yeah yeah and I had a dear friend really
step away you know that I thought was a
mentor for me and so human connection
broke yeah
and when that broke that you know was
interesting and then again I was in a
psychiatric hospital Munson in northern
Michigan
uh by Traverse City
but while I will say to go full circle
on the story
is the care that I received there
versus the 26 years was extraordinary
wow it was I mean I could actually be
cognizant of that yeah in my journey
yeah
yeah
it's so important I mean just another
thread of community that's coming
through as well too just the positive
aspects of community but also what
happens when Community is lost because
in a sense it almost sounds like maybe
this is too far but you were going
through I'm not being clinical here but
almost a morning process of losing some
connections and re-navigating and that's
something we talk about a lot I haven't
not something I've looked to in terms of
bipolar but just the importance of
community in general with mental health
how it can be protective how it can help
people navigate so all those shifts in
community losing your father which I'm
sorry to hear about as well but all
those aspects to which are foundational
and which can also add a level of stress
um so again I know you said you're
speaking as a non-clinician but I think
it's so helpful the ways that you're
pulling on all these different pieces
and how they've impacted you because I
think that's just helpful for listeners
to hear as they are their loved ones
maybe going through things and thinking
about how those things and shifts and
moves can actually have impact sometimes
in ways that I think people don't want
to necessarily acknowledge right away
for fear of maybe appearing weak or not
strong enough but they all have impacts
and again you know me speaking as a
neuroscientist knowing that those things
have impacts on our brains and how we
navigate so I mean I'm just appreciating
the way that you're
articulating that and talking through it
and giving life to it in a way that I
think will be life-giving to people who
are listening as well well I hope so and
I I think that I've always you know live
deeply you know we deeply feel deeply
there's a wonderful
I guess that's a wonderful thing
you add that termination and you add
that to loss and grieving and
and not to mention my hormonal changes I
was no longer going to have children
but you know that's emptying out I mean
that's where everything goes and that's
a very strange Dynamic and the other
thing that again not being a doctor but
it's interesting that a hormonal shift a
big one
led to a third episode yeah and a
hormonal shift of birth led to an
episode
almost exactly the same months wow apart
yeah and 26 years
you know so I think I'm a
I think it's an interesting story yeah
yeah you know and I and the blessing in
it you know the third episode I was
actually in the hospital for 12 days it
was bad um my first episode I was just
in a couple nights and I was a part of
the team in two weeks wow so we didn't
we didn't lose a beat I didn't miss a
game we just kept on moving but this one
was a little bit more complicated and
you couldn't have
you could have never told me that it
could ever happen as a matter of fact I
said to my family he said I don't even
know if I'm really by have bipolar
disorder because I haven't had an
episode in
24 years I mean not at Michigan State
not at Duke
just
how could I thought wow and I guess the
blessing was maybe this is what I'm
supposed to do learn about our brain
just a little bit more yeah and then
we'll go into this life yeah
me that there's an interesting
way to think about it too I know you
talked about being a person of faith not
to say that the episode that happening
was was
ordained per se but even in a way that
it seems like as you are launching into
this mode it's also facilitating what
you're talking about and even bringing a
deeper level of understanding and again
so many you know scientific ideas are
coming to mind even as you talk about
other hormonal changes things like that
because something that people are
looking at actively just in the way that
the hormones interact and act in our
brains and the interaction how it
impacts cognition and mental health so
there's so many different layers there
again I'm just I'm impressed at your uh
your Insight and your introspection to
be able to to know those those things as
well so
it's interesting yeah
not to fast forward too fast but to Jump
Ahead a little bit and just also to talk
about how that aspect of your journey is
impacting what you're doing now but I
guess before we get there I'm curious
how did it impact you as a coach after
you came to this realization
of having bipolar navigating it having
the treatment stopping the medication
going back going back on how did that
impact you on a daily basis and even
your perspective
love yourself and of your teams
yeah so that's kind of a long answer in
a way too
when I was 26 27 28 29
I was the toughest most unreasonable
coach
you could you know this is back in the
day okay this is where you know
discipline was everything
when I was diagnosed at 30 I became a
better person a bad person and the best
coach
I had ever been and we we want now we
won
before I was diagnosed and we won after
I was diagnosed championships beat
Stanford in the NCAA tournament all
these things but the difference was my
relatability um which I became more
intuitive I became more clear about my
surroundings and what's around me as I
work to make sure I took care of myself
and my child at the time because my
second child was born later
and um
I think that when I went to Michigan
State
I was truly in my best self wow I didn't
even have a psych
in the state
I walked out of my psych in Maine I
would see her once a year wow and we
would connect and I would do my lithium
levels and
I didn't have a therapist or anything we
were just moving along and play for a
national championship in five years
and I use that cycle because that's a
pretty quick way to get to a national
title game yeah yeah and I was recruited
by Duke I went to Northwestern but loved
Duke and so when I was recruited by Dave
to coach it was sort of like wow you
know what an opportunity
and Gail had done such a tough job I
mean an incredible job and what I mean
by tough it was a tough to follow such a
legend yeah and but the way I saw it was
perhaps I could be some kind of
Difference Maker many people told me not
to take the job because there was no
movement upwards basically I mean there
was National Championship or forget it
you know and I thought that was kind of
cool you know it's like this is going to
be great and when I got to Duke I just
loved the team there was wonderful
Talent
we developed wonderful Talent we worded
wonderful Talent we went to four
straight Elite AIDS it was very hard to
break through we lost to Maya Moore in
Connecticut we got a Greiner so breaking
through the final four proved to be very
difficult
and we recruit some great players
Chelsea Gray and grecky and all of those
and um but we you know played at the
highest level yeah and it was so
exciting it was met with so many
challenges I I just can't even tell you
I mean for so many reasons that makes
sense it wasn't a rebuild you know and
I'm still at my best self and I think
the thing that people may not understand
is
as a demanding coach
you have your moments often in the
locker room at half time
maybe after a game yes that too
in practice closed doors but
I was my best self
and
you have great relationships with
players
and you have some that are not so hot
where you don't connect and that's
always sad because you remember those
yeah sometimes more than the ones that
you do connect yeah but yet I also had
to tackle a player with a panic attack
well see I recognize that
I had education about it yeah and I
wanted I wanted support from our team I
wanted I wanted quick access to
Psychiatry if me
and so I pushed the envelope a little
bit there you know and we did we did
different things you know hiring a
strength coach and all these things
um but I will say that
I was very fortunate to have some great
years coaching and maintain balance by
basically being kind of a boring person
you know too routine your family yeah
having a dog
you know all these things in place and
and that's why I worry about young
people that don't have all these
mechanisms
you know you can really fight through
for your children
you know of course for your partner or
spouse but it's not the same
I mean it's your children and you've got
to
you know step up and really stay with
your routine you're swimming or whatever
it is and but I think of young people
today
what if they don't have they don't have
those connectors
and they're not old enough
to understand I mean I was 30 when
diagnosed
it just it drives me a lot to think
about the loneliness that that they feel
because I have definitely been there
yeah
so well said I mean I'm still just
processing all the different pieces that
you've you've pulled out and get into
this last point of just the impact
and thinking about young people and
those that you're you're you've
navigated with and coached and mentored
the way that you are intuitive to it
even something you said early on about
how this made you a better Coach and a
better person because some may have
assumed that the way you characterize
being disciplinary before was the most
effective but sounds like there was
another layer on top of that that you're
really able to tap into that kind of
carried you through
with all these different aspects and
just again I guess I'm I'm going back to
the community again it seemed like it it
enhanced that aspect of community and
the ways that you engaged in community
just in terms of perspective yes and you
can trust again after all the sadness
trust is a big issue and not just
trusting yourself but trusting your
players it's no secret that we end up
beating Stanford after I'm on meds right
we do something incredible uh because
we're there's trust and there's a
balance of energy of course I yelled at
that team
you know but but there's an overall
respect in care and again you know
through that Journey at Michigan State
and Duke there's definitely been that
respect in care but the trust Factor
changes when you become diagnosed when
you can trust your doctors
well listen to your doctors don't go It
Alone Now I always say the minute you
think you can do it alone
that's exactly the time
and I just can't stress yeah that's
really really important advice and I
think that's something that people need
to hear and need to hear over and over
again because in the moment that tension
will definitely come back in terms of
trying to navigate although onto here
someone who has walked through and just
to know the importance of staying
connected and building that trust I
think is is critical
I'm also curious I guess I'm going to
expand on the trust idea a little bit
and even make it bigger to a societal
sense because part of your story is also
the aspect of being diagnosed early on
but not sharing it broadly and the
counsel that you got versus what we're
seeing now with a lot of people who are
being more open about that earlier on to
encourage others but it's still
challenging still something for people
to walk through where do you think we
are as a society in terms of that trust
are we giving people the space to walk
in that or is it just
just lip service and and
I don't know the best way to put it yeah
I understand bossing over in a sense and
that when it comes down to the real how
we really treat people are we really I
guess are we really
walking authentic trust or just a facade
I know that's a way that's a way to not
to put all that on you but well it's a
selective space
that we're allowed in
upon going public after leaving Duke I
actually had a
a Blog somewhere say how dare I could
not share that publicly
I was shamed for not sharing and the
thing about it is is that when I was
given the advice
by a doctor
the advice was
extremely important because it was said
and I believe this that it would have
all been about me I would be in a press
conference if I had gotten upset usually
in games I was pretty you know things I
on the sidelines we're in the bunker
together you know so practices were I
was tougher in practice
is tougher
um but still it would have taken away
from them
you know they would ask questions I
would have been studied and looked up
and of course the negative recruiting
would have been yeah incredible so I
think the answer is in selective spaces
people can if they're ready share
but many times people still cannot share
and people said would you go back to
coaching I wouldn't change what I'm
doing I did not take a salary I'm
raising money for a foundation
I had been working as hard as I've ever
worked but I do kind of pick my spots
yeah which is nice and set my own you
know schedule yeah I used to have a nice
salary
Once Upon a Time
um not when I started in coaching but
later in coaching and so I do set my
schedule and it's wonderful and it's
coaching lots and lots of people but
if I wanted to go back into coaching
basketball I don't think I could
because it would take a visionary
they would take an athletic director
that wasn't always looking over her
shoulder
which most of them do
and I love athletic direct troops I I've
worked for many fabulous ones but I have
to say
it's getting a little bit plastic
in regard to
Teflon everything bounces off everything
bounces off of people you know it's it's
everyone's actually operating from Fear
and so I don't think I would be hiring
that if even if I wanted that to be the
case
yeah and that's really
poignant as well I mean I think to your
point that fear is there I'm assuming
you're talking about even without
thinking about the mental health
aspect and so you had yeah I mean I
think later on in navigating yeah I just
think that as a woman you know I am not
a bipolar coach a coach with bipolar
disorder exactly and that's a big
distinction yeah and frankly I'm the
best coach I've ever been right now at
57
coaching
every human that is in front of me or
giving me the opportunity and I'll say
coaching because I'm not a doctor I'm
not a therapist
I know a lot about CBT because it was
used with me right right well I mean I
paid attention and I studied
I studied this whole these dynamics of
depression anxiety and and how it
manifests and what the value of my swim
is five times a week and all those
things I I have a I have some referent
power that I think can be very helpful
yeah I totally agree and to follow up on
that what is so what is uh maybe not a
daily schedule but what is the
day-to-day look like for you how are you
how are you doing that coaching at this
point and integrating I mean as we're
talking I'm thinking integrating
your coaching knowledge your basketball
knowledge just your your insights into
mental health to this full kind of
onset of tools that you can give people
well it's interesting I used to have my
schedule set for me
um yep
when it's you know seven days a week our
objectives 24 7. you know you know the
drop okay so that was that now I have to
make sure and be more diligent than ever
in creating my own schedule
that free time and idle time leads to
ruminating and with a depressed person
with an answer person with someone with
bipolar disorder and a person having a
bad day yeah and so
scheduling my morning time my writing
time my devotional time
you know that that can't be missed
and initially I was missing that because
I used to get up at 5 30 in the morning
to have that time and then of course I
stopped getting up at 5 30 in the
morning but then I would roll through
the morning and then I didn't do any of
my thinking wow and it took me a while
to come back to that so wait a minute
Joanne you this is part of who you are
yeah and so you schedule the days you
schedule things and you spend time with
the flowers and you know you schedule
time though to stay very busy and my my
swim is five or six days a week it's not
negotiable I'm a member of the Y I swim
wherever I speak oh wow yeah especially
if I can do that day of talk that's
weird
um but my weight lifting you know is not
for vanity although I like that I'm in
shape yeah yeah well that's a very good
oh gosh not only for bones but for your
mind that's a good one yeah and I talk
about water therapy a lot you know
bathing and
um sweat is water what is really
important and
um and eating you know eating it roughly
the same times
you know taking care of yourself I don't
even eat after 7 30 and people say well
that's interesting I said well I don't
feel like it my body doesn't like it you
know and it's a healthier way to live
yeah and so
you know it's not a Pious thing you
learn this works yeah you know walking
the dog every day that's a really good
thing yeah not to mention the dog liking
it yeah
you know so it's
it's not rocket science but it is
discipline
and it is awareness
to yourself yeah and if you're not
sleeping well
you need to be pay attention yeah and
make time for that
um because it's critically important and
obviously I've learned all this and if I
could give this wisdom to whomever and
just you know cut short their learning
curve just a little bit Yeah Yeah
because I wouldn't want people to have
to go through what I went through if you
can help them yeah
and I appreciate hearing I mean it's so
clear how your passion is spilling
through and everything you do even as
you're sharing all these tips even
before you said to help others I mean I
could just sense that to that you can
you really want others to be able to get
this so they can put these things in
place and really have that full life as
you talked about too and the importance
of all those routines that you've
mentioned the dog walking that's its own
interesting aspect itself so we had a
couple of guests who came out and talked
about social bonding and oxytocin that's
released in our brain there's some
really interesting studies actually
about people and dog interactions and
how that also facilitates oxytocin and
so even what you're talking about just
Taps into a lot of those aspects of how
it's good for for us and for our brains
in general and just all I mean all the
things you mentioned I'm going to put a
Shameless plug in here as well because
my dad actually joined for one of the
episodes because he's a sleep position
and just talked about so many specific
aspects of sleep hygiene that you talked
about all the impacts that it has on
mental health and ways we can adjust and
and notice things are arrive so I mean
everything that you've mentioned just
resonates in so many ways and I'm so
glad that you're sharing that
um with others as well
wow you come from quite a family
I agree you guys are pretty smart I
don't know that's pretty smart stuff
getting through all that orgo I mean yes
I had good Role Models but as I've
shared in some other instances it took
me a minute to incorporate that into my
own story so that that's a whole other
story itself in terms of the uh
what should we call the uh
factor of putting myself into it versus
the laziness so that's that was a
journey as well
um but yeah I definitely have great
examples
um from both of my parents both from
opportunities they both grew up in Ghana
West Africa but then also from their
faith perspective and just the
opportunities they created for us and
letting us come to that space of
learning to navigate so a lot of ways it
kind of ties in with the things that
you've talked about you know when you
think about your children and how we
pass those things along but also create
those opportunities so yeah yeah I know
it's a tangent but I had to go there
because you brought it
that's a great story that would be an
amazing book well I appreciate that and
I shouldn't I shouldn't give away too
many Secrets but listeners don't know
but I'm actually thinking about the book
project so since you mentioned that
right I'll just throw that out there and
say there are things in the works good
but I'm going to pull now I'm nine
Neuroscience is coming back in because
you know it's so helpful to hear you
talk about all these practical tips and
I always think about how it impacts the
brain I turn out to be too Centric on
the brain but again that's that's my
expertise in the area of of work but
I'll know that you have also talked
about the importance of how we have to
be able to understand the power of our
brains and so I'm curious what you mean
when you say that and how you navigate
that when you're sharing with audiences
or individuals as well well I think that
you know a balance brain is the smartest
brain the brain can be right so you so
we're all going to work for balance and
we all have different Journeys to that
balance and for me I've had to negotiate
through my life
again being an athlete I didn't want any
foreign substance in my body and I knew
I could overcome anything
I've had to adjust
I've had to learn to listen I've been on
lithium
since the first day I was diagnosed I'm
a big lithium Advocate I know that
everyone cannot take it I feel sad for
that I feel like lithium is the best
drug and you know as you know founded
ears I mean many moons ago I had to
learn about Lamictal another powerful
medicine and I am a lithium Lamictal
person and they have played off each
other and I even gave birth
to a son while taking lithium and that
there's very little research yeah done
on that and that wasn't that was it but
obviously a different time and a long
time ago he was born in 2000.
and
so I feel like then I've understood what
klonopin can do
I you know certain things I don't like
you know certain drugs Restoril is not
my favorite I could not do a commercial
for restaurant
addictive quality of it and getting off
of it and the health and I thought for
me I'm not talking to a listener out
there who says wow that works great yeah
it's all very independent and that's but
you have to be a scientist to some
degree you have to study you have to
wonder how these things can affect you
there have been times you know I had
kidney complications because of lithium
there was a pullback on lithium but then
that was premature my kidney
regentrified in a way that didn't make a
whole lot of sense to Medicine
so I've had some interesting
complications and I just think that
if we're going to know our brains
you have to study all facets of it and
recognize that alcohol is something I
can do in very small moderation but
let's face it I don't need to be
drinking while I'm taking some of these
medications and I can tell you that
Zyprexa
is a
mind-numbing experience that actually
became necessary for me at one time I
couldn't believe the power of that girl
I love Gabapentin okay all-time favorite
non-addictive qualities healthy sleep so
you know and then Klonopin is an
all-time favorite because it you know it
works kind of quickly and you can feel
that you can feel your chest you know
anxiety is something I've had reading
coaching
I've had more anxiety leading protein
than I did coaching in front of 30 000.
wow
it's really again it's really nothing
there's more unknown there I would say
yeah
I just throw those out there because you
might have a listener Center having to
work with these medicines and but you
have to be your Advocate you have to be
educated and I when I talk with people
and they're saying well I really don't
know how much I take I'm like okay wait
a minute yeah
go get your bottles like are you kidding
you even know what you're taking how
much and again you can't read though on
the internet all these things yeah
it's crazy how much you know all these
things that they say so you stick with
your doctors and you try to test them
and learn from them and
so I guess your question was about you
know Max how we maximize our brain
health and or we become educated about
it and I do talk to folks on a bipolar
disorder and I do remind them that
didn't go and others of great prowess
we're known to have bipolar disorder and
I do tell them that that means you have
a brilliant mind except you have to find
your way through the maze yeah you get
there yeah wow that's so well said
that's so well said
and I was on Netflix to tell me best
best um compliment I ever got wasn't oh
you won all these gains I had an ad and
I love him he said you are
super smart
and I said yes yeah and you know and I
can say that because I've been going
through the maze yeah and just when I
thought I had the mace
I was given a much more sophisticated
thing yeah yeah
highly agree and it just makes me think
about I mean there's scripture passage
of being about being tested not being
tested beyond what we can hear and just
even just hearing that in your story and
the way that you talked about all those
pieces as you got to a certain level of
understanding as you're sharing that
with others and then another twist comes
along the way but I mean yeah well the
faith thing I do want to interject
because I feel so comfortable when I'm
around people of Faith because it's more
important to me and um I started with
John 14 27. and um
you know this is all about fear and now
let your heart be troubled people and I
feel like my whole life
for most of it I've been afraid and
scared about so many things I had to go
through and then as I transitioned
Esther 414 no such a time as this new
testament old testament coming together
and I realized that these tattoos were I
got them over 50.
[Music]
I've got a lot of time to think about it
right and then I you know when I have my
tough moments I do this
um wow you know it's a form of this yeah
like this wow and um for me that that
has been extremely and Esser uh the Book
of Esther is extraordinary to me because
of she does everything she can you know
she and I I feel like a lot of women
um or men for that matter but a lot of
women could relate to the sacrifice and
The anter Savvy enter intelligence
yeah yeah that's so I appreciate your
your willingness and and comfort in
sharing that as well because I think
that's so important been such an
important part of your story and it's a
lot of what we've talked about on this
podcast as well just the the power of
faith and what God allows us to navigate
and through these different situations
and to make sure that that's an
integrated conversation
um because in two in too many instances
just in conversations that I've had with
people where people are trying to
separate those things so I mean that's
something that's just coming through in
your story even as you talked about the
medications as you talked about the fear
that you had to navigate and you were
acknowledging spending time doing your
devotions in the morning and just all
these different aspects it's
in a sense I mean it seems like it's an
ongoing learning experience and that's
been the power I mean even as you were
sharing about all those aspects I hope
the listeners called that too about the
mindset shift that you had about not
when you put any medications
in your body to knowing that we do have
these tools that can impact our brains
and help us navigate but then we also
have the tools that we can meditate on
scripture that can also help us navigate
and again my Neuroscience again all
those things impact our brains and so I
often feel like these are all the tools
that God's given us to be able to move
through and walk through these
situations so it's actually beautiful to
hear you to hear you say that and uh it
was beautiful wait what's beautiful is
that you're in Academia
and Ivy League Institution
being able to express the merging of all
of these things
and I went to Northwestern so I know
what these worlds are like and
many times you know
faith is so pushed aside
you know and I just do not understand
how everyone has their thing right so
your property Karma whatever it is okay
whatever you have use it but wisdom it's
got to be part of it okay so I get my
wisdom from the Bible and Psalm or
Proverbs okay that's where I get my
wisdom where do you get your wisdom you
know I always joke I'm a Buddhist
Christian
I don't know if I've heard that before
I really I sometimes I do because in
reading about things you know often do
not talk about my faith
um and I've been told not to talk about
my food but if I don't have the Right
audience
you know and one of my one of my things
I'm looking forward to someday is to get
on the stage of a church and
really let it go I don't know what I
would say at that point but you know you
just feel like you'd be in a safe space
so I seldom bring Faith into it although
I'm a secret Warrior the book I do I
have a chapter on faith because the way
I come around to Faith is almost comical
it's baptized over 50. wow yeah so it
it's kind of it is kind of funny to me
yeah that's the way things happen
sometimes yeah well I look forward to
reading through and actually I mean I
always encourage listeners to listen to
or read through you know different
products and books that our guests have
as well but I mean to your point I think
that's it's been a positive shift over
time so I know I keep looping back to my
dad but when he was on the episode as
well
one of the things that he shared was
just the fact that we were having the
conversation that we were having on this
podcast that has published broadcast by
Yale in the public space and how he
couldn't he would not have seen those
things 30 years ago when he was training
in Psychiatry and the way this shift has
come and then others who have come on
the podcast as well and just talked
about the importance of not dismissing
people and I mean that's been one of our
themes too to just think about how we
approach mental health in general and
not be dismissive of any one approached
but that includes whether someone has a
faith background or not not dismissing
an aspect that is so Central to who
somebody is and so I mean for me I did
do some training with some Clinical
Psychology interns in New York and it
was encouraging to see the way the field
has shifted to say okay we need to
actually understand people's life's
experiences if we're trying to meet them
where they are we can't you know the old
school idea was that you don't talk
about faith and therapy or certain taboo
topics but then how do you ignore a
whole aspect
of who somebody is
um and like you said the power that
comes with that and the way that people
navigate so for me it's been really
encouraging to be able to step into
these spaces and then to also see people
be receptive to thinking about things in
a more integrated manner in our academic
spaces and our faith communities
um because for me and my listeners have
heard me say it's before to me it's
always distressing if there's this
mission on either side so someone is
coming from a purely scientific lens and
dismisses the power of faith
or if someone's coming from a faith
perspective and dismisses all that we
know about science even as you were
talking about all those effects those
medications have had how they've been
possible we can't ignore that and
pretend it's not there so again you know
my listeners like he's going off on that
again but it's a passion and I have a
like-minded individual here with me so
yes very much so and I you said it
extremely well and in our world where
there's so much separation you know can
we look for commonality and with
commonality doesn't match up perfectly
somebody believes in Karma great but
just wisdom can we all agree that wisdom
is a good thing and where do you get it
and I know the way I found it I wasn't
brought up in any kind of Faith
background whatsoever so I know the way
I came about and we all need to find a
way to come about with it it's something
that gives us wisdom yeah because life
is too complicated yeah you can't do
this alone yeah you know and so I I just
oh I Marvel at what you're saying and
that gives me great inspiration for what
the reputations are you know out there
with the Ivory Tower that doesn't relate
on many levels and then finally I had a
psychiatrist save me once which was
really funny when I was having a weaker
moment he said
do you have any faith is there anything
about that and at the time I did I was
like well yeah and he said okay let's
review that what's it all about so I I
love it
yeah you know the whole push-pull and
how it can all work together yeah yeah
definitely that's a great segue to what
I wanted to close with too because we
mentioned the hope that that gives you
and I just was going to have you just
share you know what gives you hope on a
day-to-day basis and in the place where
you are right now in life
oh gosh so many things give me hope I
mean this podcast
I mean your work and all of your
colleagues and and the direction we're
moving you know we haven't arrived and
of course we never arrive and so it's a
process and we're in this process but
it's picking up steam and the
understandings are becoming more clear
and I feel I had a great faith in people
and the strength of people
and I just feel that we're we're
churning to come together you know like
it's it's starting to develop where we
realize that all we have is each other
and The Human Experience and I think I
feel that I know when I speak and I
speak to different people obviously I'm
thrilled if my story can help just a
little bit yeah and I'm particularly
thrilled when it helps young people you
know you know those young people that
are just really struggling I look at my
son
and losing almost two years at
Northwestern and the pain that that is
awesome and this going back to school is
wonderful except
they're seeing what they didn't get yeah
you know it's sort of and yes we should
not look backwards absolutely she
present-minded but young people
can't always be present-minded yeah you
know so there's a lot of complicating
things in our world right now but I have
tremendous faith in humanity and um I
just hope to do my part well I think you
definitely are and I I know I mean even
in this hour that we've had just the
things that you've shared I know
definitely you doing your part in that
way as well and I know that this is
really going to be encouraging to
listeners I imagine people will go back
and listen to Parts again a lot of the
nuggets and the wisdom just that you
shared from your experience the lessons
you learned along the way
um and how important that is and so so
many different ways so I definitely
think you're making that impact I'm
proud to be able to to know you and have
this conversation
um even Beyond The Duke part although
that was that was the foundation that
entered the Duke Mental Health
conglomeration yeah
Duke Duke yeah got a lot of that going
yeah yeah which is why I got excited
when I saw your background I got it yeah
yeah but again I mean I'm just so
grateful for for the worth you're doing
and even the way that you just shared so
so wisely and candidly
um in this last hour I think it's
something that people will really be
able to uh to hear things that will
resonate insights that people will have
and so I mean for me it's just it's an
hour to be a facilitator in a sense to
just be here and let people come and
share all these pieces of knowledge and
experience with our listeners so deeply
indebted to you for for taking the time
for your investment and for what you're
continuing to do thank you doc I love
docs
you guys do great work and I so
appreciate you having me
foreign
[Music]